Hollywood mogul Harvey Weinstein is
expected in court today as his
long-awaited criminal trial begins
allegations of sexual misconduct against
Weinstein by more than 80 women fueled
the rise of the me2 movement Weinstein
is formally charged with sexually
assaulting two women one in 2006 and
another in 2013 CBS this morning
national correspondent Jericka Duncan is
at the courthouse in New York with a
broadcast interview you'll see only on
CBS this morning
Jericka good morning Anthony just to set
the scene there is a line behind me that
started forming at about four o'clock
this morning for this trial now we did
sit down with three women who call
themselves Silence breakers they are not
going to take the stand but they're
among a larger group many of whom will
be here this morning and say they are
here to support the several women who
plan to testify against Harvey Weinstein
I feel very emotional actress Rosanna
Arquette says she never thought she
would see Harvey Weinstein face a jury
Hey Arquette appeared in the 1994
Weinstein produced film pulp fiction in
2017 she told The New Yorker that in the
early 90s Weinstein forcibly came on to
her in a hotel room and when she
rejected him
her career suffered Hari Weinstein plays
dirty
he always has and I guess he always will
our cat spoke to us alongside Jasmine
Loeb and Louise God bolts and the women
are not involved in Y stands trial but
say they are survivors of his sexual
misconduct so many people have stepped
forward and said this happened to us to
something similar we do not want this
man roaming around and we have to bring
it back to that the 67 year old is
charged with predatory sexual assault
and first and third degree rape for two
separate incidents he has pleaded not
guilty and denies all allegations of
non-consensual sex CBS News legal
analyst Ricky Kleman what matters the
most chair is the charge of predatory
sexual assault that becomes the charge
that carries the day he is facing 10
years to life in a statement Weinstein
told CBS News quote there are a number
of things that I would have liked to
have done differently and I do empathize
with those who feel hurt however he
added I am looking forward to setting
the record straight and yes I am
expecting to be fully exonerated is that
something you guys worry about if he is
not convicted of these crimes that he
will come back yes I think that's it's
totally possible I want to say to the
witnesses thank you for testifying just
tell your truth and whatever happens we
pray that justice will prevail
tareka Duncan reporting we thank you
that trial is expected to last by the
way for at least two months
you